as the second of Ridley Scott's alien
prequels alien covenant picks up on the
scenes we saw in Prometheus and
continues to build a backstory for the
xenomorph we first met in Scotts 1979
alien movie yippee-ki-yay movie lovers
it's Jan here and in this video I want
to take a look at some of the Easter
eggs and details and alien covenant that
only diehard fans will have spotted do
let me know about your favorite Easter
eggs or any others you spotted in the
comments below and also subscribe for a
chance to win this awesome alien
covenant merchandise I've got two packs
to give away and each one includes a
t-shirt a cap a keychain bottle opener
metal playing cards and a set of pin
badges obviously there are spoilers
ahead for alien covenant so be aware of
that or come back here after you've seen
the movie when the Covenant crew land on
the planet two of the team were infected
with neo morph spores after they
disturbed the local flora causing the
spores to be released into the air and
enter their ears or nostrils this
airborne means of infection is actually
a callback to a rejected script for
alien 3 by writer William Gibson
Gibson's story which would have been the
sequel to director James Cameron's
aliens movie explored the theme of
genetically altering xenomorph into bio
weapons and this idea also links to
David's experiments in Alien Covenant
and how he combined the lethal black
liquid pathogen with DNA from the
engineers and Elizabeth Shaw to produce
his own experimental alien creations
during the confrontation between david
and walter david quotes one of the most
famous lines from John Milton's epic
poem Paradise Lost in which Satan
declares better to reign in Hell than
serve in heaven there's a parallel
between David's story and alien covenant
in Prometheus and how he turned against
the humans he served and the themes of
Milton's Paradise Lost which tells a
story of the fallen angel Lucifer and
how he corrupted mankind in the Garden
of Eden after he was banished to hell
when he rebelled against God by the way
Paradise Lost was the original title for
the Prometheus sequel until it was
changed to covenant and that title
change is interesting because in the
poem Paradise Lost
Adam experiences a vision of future
events right up until the biblical Great
Flood which ties in with the idea of the
Covenant God made with Noah who built
the ark that saved humanity and the
animals and just like the biblical story
of the Ark and the great flood where
each species
came in twos did he notice how all the
crew on the Covenant are couples and at
the end of the movie David himself also
brought a pair of alien embryos onto the
Covenant ship and the seed of David's
rebellion against mankind was planted
during that opening scene in Alien
Covenant where we see the first moments
of David's creation and self-awareness
with Peter Weyland in that scene in
Whelan's room David names himself after
the statue of Michelangelo's David
likely because he felt that looking at
the Statue of David was in some ways
like looking in a mirror
in other words both synthetic and statue
were perfect creations that would long
outlive their human craters intriguingly
though the choice of David and Walter
for the names of the two synthetics and
alien covenant is actually in a marsh
the producers of all the alien movies
alien covenant features a drinking bird
toy that has appeared in several of the
alien movies starting with Ridley
Scott's 1979 film I'm curious as to
whether this is just an easter egg or
whether there's a deeper meaning to the
repeated placement of the toy bird on
various ships perhaps it's just a fun
souvenir from home or could it suggests
the monotony of their lives onboard or
maybe the reason it's there is hinted at
in prometheus where a programmed message
plays after the crew wake up encouraging
them to drink enough water along with
the original alien movie one of Ridley
Scott's best-known sci-fi films is
1982's Blade Runner starring Harrison
Ford and there are a number of Easter
eggs and possible links between Blade
Runner and alien covenant for example
this emergency signal which appears in
Blade Runner also appears in covenant as
well as Prometheus and one of the scenes
and alien covenant tips its hat to a
scene in Blade Runner
when Daniels uses a nail to stab David
he mocked her saying that's the spirit
in Blade Runner batty impales his own
hand with a nail and moments later
towards Deckard as they fight with the
line that's the spirit Ridley Scott is
also a producer on the sequel Blade
Runner 20:49 and that movies trailer
teases a suspended humanoid figure which
bears some similarity to the engineers
from the alien movies with both films
coming out this year and apparent Easter
eggs and references between the two
movies could this be Ridley Scott
hinting at a possible shared universe
talking of crossovers as a nod to
predator in the scene on the Covenant
where the alien chases Daniels and
Tennessee through the ship we get a
point of view shot for the alien as it
hunts the remaining pair of crew members
but the predator franchise is no
stranger to this type of POV shot and of
course that franchise crossed over with
the Alien franchise in the alien versus
Predator movies so were there any other
Easter eggs or alien connections you
spotted an alien covenant and what do
you think about a possible crossover
between alien and Blade Runner don't
forget to comment about the movie and
subscribe for your chance to win one of
these awesome alien Covenant merch packs
and be sure to turn on notifications for
my new videos where I'll be announcing
the winners if you like this video do
please hit that thumbs up button and you
can check out more of my alien and
Easter egg videos by tapping the screen
right here thanks for watching and see
you next time
yippee-ki-yay movie lovers